all right hello everybody
all right I see already I see Jacob in
the chat good to see you Jacob and hear
other people as well thanks Jacob for
being around that's always good okay so
a few things I want to talk about before
we start I guess there's a lot of things
going on the first thing that I need to
mention is that there has been a massive
drop in my youtube views and when I'm
listening to other youtubers it seems
like I'm not the only person to whom
this has happened so it seemed it's
probably the YouTube algorithm obviously
as you've noticed I've been pushing the
envelope in terms of my content and in
terms of the types of things that I'm
that I'm mentioning so it seems like
after I made the video which was called
who was it called from equality to
inversion that video started on the
first date spiked like crazy and I was
and I couldn't believe it I think within
two days it added like 30,000 views and
then it's then I just suddenly tapered
off and just stopped growing and so I
was kind of freaked out and then since
then um I have seen my views go down
almost systematically on every single
video so maybe it's because I'm saying
crazy things
it is possible maybe it's because of you
guys in the chat saying crazy things I
see a few crazy things there already
um maybe that's what it is I don't know
but so anyway so all I can say is if you
like what I'm doing the best thing you
can do is to share the content because
I'm I'm not friends with you to it at
this moment it seems like YouTube
doesn't really like what I'm doing for a
while there they were they were they
were they were sharing my content but
for now at this morning at this moment
that doesn't seem to be happening so
alright um there are a few big things on
the horizon as well for those who
haven't heard that yet I'm going to be
turning
my website into a multi-user blog and so
on the website you're gonna be you're
gonna find some articles on symbolism
coming from different perspectives I
have been working with some of the main
people on the Facebook group that have
been posting some really good stuff and
I was reading a lot of the posts on
there and I thought man this stuff is
just it's just the best just top level
stuff and so with a few of with a core
group of of those writers and then a lot
of great people that have volunteered to
proofread and to edit we're going to
start having the we're gonna start
putting out some articles and the blogs
and become the the website it's going to
become like a like a blog on different
symbolic subjects exploring all the
things that I don't have time to talk
about hopefully within the same kind of
symbolic frame another a few other
things I'm gonna be in Seattle on the
first week of May I'll be giving a talk
at the shared inheritance conference
like before and I'm also going to be
giving a workshop a carving workshop
during that week and so stay tuned to my
website for that soon there'll be dates
and ways to sign up for those events I'm
also going to be in Hartford Connecticut
in the month of June with the same thing
giving a carving workshop like I told
you guys before these carving workshops
obviously they're carving workshops but
they're also just spending the whole day
together we start in the morning and we
usually end you know later in the
evening and so it's just a great it's
just a great time to get to know each
other and to have some great discussions
okay so here we go I'm gonna start the
questions with the website and you
notice that I'm coughing a lot and I'm
super paranoid that I might have the
corona virus or something because when I
flew to Boston on February 14th I am I
found out just a few days ago that it
seems like the first case of corona
virus in our area was in the airport on
February the 14th and so now I'm like
freaking out because when I got back
from Boston I got a cold and I've been
like coughing and stuff so and like a
bit nervous about that stuff so luckily
I can't transmit the corona virus
through the camera all right so as you
know people who are patrons of mine on
the different platforms at ten dollars
or more get to ask questions in advance
and then if we have time I will look
into the chat for super chats and so
here we go so Benjamin r-va asks you've
mentioned that Constantinople was
designed to be an iconic city a divine
image can you elaborate on any elements
of that of sources where we could learn
more about the meaning behind the
Byzantine built environment or sacred
patterns in urbanism in general I have
to be honest and I don't know a lot
about that I don't know a lot about I
know a basic idea of how Constantinople
was set up one of the things that's
interesting about Constantinople is that
it was a the first city that was built
without any pagan temples in it and so
you can imagine everybody in Rome is
there and they're all these like
residues of the temples that are still
hanging around some temples are still
functional some are being taken down all
of this is kind of it's kind of brouhaha
is happening and then Constantine you
know picks up it goes to you know goes
to Constantinople to Byzantium and then
builds a new capital there that has you
know the palace and his church in the
center it's kind of like a hill kind of
and so um you know and it's kind of it's
surrounded by water so there's all that
symbolism as well as almost like a
microcosm of the world um but if you're
looking to learn a little bit more about
that there's a man his name is timothy
petits a-- he teaches at the hellenic
college in in the u.s near boston and i
think i might have him on the channel he
just wrote a book recently and and
contacted me said he'd like me to check
out his book so maybe i'll have him on
the channel i know he has written about
the notion of the city as liturgy and
city life as a liturgical comparing it
to like liturgical experience so i think
that might be something that could be
interesting so you might see that in the
near future honey coughing between every
question all right so Josh the mover
asks hi Jonathan God willing I'm
planning on becoming Orthodox this year
unless I relocate and find a new job
the only tenable option for me is a
Greek Orthodox Church the next town over
ideally I wish I could join the Russian
Church how important of an issue are
these communal ecclesiastical issues for
a new Orthodox can you expand on these
schisms why they occur and how they are
result so the schism between the Greek
Church and the Russian Church is and is
is happening at the level of the
authorities and even the authorities
both in the Greek and the Russian Church
is my understanding that they've
insisted that this is not for the for
the communicants that is for us as
believers in the church it is not a
breaking communion for us that is we
have no problem with Greeks Greeks on
their problems with Russian in theory
the misunderstanding is not a is not a
theological misunderstanding it is a
jurisdictional misunderstanding it is a
fight about territories and about
Authority and about power and so because
of that know whichever Orthodox Church
you join that is in communion that are
in communion with a broader Orthodox
Church is totally fine the the
difficulty you're going to you're going
to face is that some churches are so
let's say ethnic or that are based on
ethnic based so much on ethnic questions
that sometimes it makes it a little
difficult for an outsider to to join in
and to really feel like they're part of
the church so that's something that you
have to see with the priest with the
community you know there are some Greek
communities that have been here for a
few generations and they're completely
you know they're completely fine and
they're not hostile to outsiders it just
really depends on your situation on
where you are
um so I would say just move one step at
a time meet with the priest tell of the
priest your your worries um and
hopefully he can just engage with you
about that
so Adam shall art asked how does one go
about breaking down the negative
principalities patterns in our life um I
mean I would say prayer I know it sounds
just so easy it's easy to say that and I
agree because obviously just like all of
you there are some negative patterns in
my life that I you know that I struggle
to get rid of but nonetheless I'm I know
that that's the right way to go about
you know and engaging in the sacramental
life for the church mmm going to
confession taking that seriously you
know and every time you go to confession
try to see it as as a new beginning and
not just something that you do you know
and just so that you can take communion
but rather see it as a kind of cleaning
the slate and then the new beginning so
that hopefully you can anchor yourself
and and start again you know when you go
to confession that's the best I could do
you know if you can have a good
spiritual father
that's probably useful because they can
give you advice and they can have
authority over you to kind of ask you to
do certain things but it's hard to do it
on your own and I say that because I I
feel like I also struggle because I
don't I have a confessor but I don't
have what I would call the spiritual
father in the sense he's a great
confessor but I don't think he feels
very involved in my in my spiritual
struggle then say hopefully one day I
can find a more involved spiritual
father
so Keenan Cronin asks I really struggled
to understand what Paul says on us being
free from the law of Moses and that
God's law is now written on our heart
seemingly for us to work out for
ourselves then at the same time it still
seems like we should follow certain Old
Testament laws what's your understanding
of this so my understanding of this is
that you know if you read if you read
st. Paul st. Paul is very difficult to
read you know but if you read say Paul
he'll say things
you know like we're we're we are above
the law you know we've been freed from
the law the law and our hearts and then
he'll ask well does that mean that we
should break the law and he says by no
means we shouldn't break the law right
we should follow the law and so what is
going on there the idea is that as you
enter into Christ as you let's say at
you know it's the same as when Saint
Paul says you know in Christ there is
neither Greek nor Jew there's neither
man nor woman there's never slave nor
free you know and you think he's like
okay I guess but then Paul turns around
and he says slaves obey your master you
know he says you know women submit to
your husband's he says submit to one
another to your authority as to as to
God himself and so it's like you know
what's going on and so the idea is that
think of it that think of it as the
mountain you know it's like you you
ascend the mountain you enter into the
heart all that imagery and then you
reach the point of the divine logos and
you you reach the Holy of Holies you go
beyond the veils of the heart whoever
expression that the Mystics use and then
when you reach that place you find this
spark that is contains in it everything
and therefore is beyond the specifics of
the law is beyond the the the the
multiplicity of the law it's like says
if the law is kind of taken into this
one place and you see Christ tried to do
that even when he's speaking to try to
show that space to you when he says
things like you know all the law on the
Prophet is in his result his resorbed
him you know love love love the love
your God and your neighbor as yourself
and so it's like he's trying to show you
how all the law kind of if you have love
then you have all the law and so but the
the problem is that when you go back
down the mountain it doesn't mean that
the law doesn't reappear or that certain
things don't really know if that makes
sense
and so and so
a good quite a good question a good way
to see it is this it's like if I'm in
the heart and I and let's say I'm in
Christ then if I find driving down the
street and I see somebody who wants to
cross then I'll stop and I'll let them
cross in front of me and it's like you
know I'm doing it out of the love of
Christ in me but if but it still means
that there might be a rule which says
that if you come to a crosswalk and the
person is in front of you you have to
stop to let them pass so those two
things are not contradictory it's just
that one is like this outer expression
of what you should be able to find in
your heart in terms of something which
is is beyond the multiplicity of just
legal prescriptions so that's how I see
it
I hope this might hope that make sense
all right so David flora says in the
last Q&A you said some legends say
Merlin was the son of a dragon and I've
read somewhere he was the son of a devil
yeah or the son of a theory what pattern
is he manifesting because it seems that
he would ally himself with evil
principalities rather than good ones
especially since in some legends he's
involved in the subterfuge of Arthur's
birth and other mischievous acts and so
I think that the character of Merlin he
is he represents how the things that are
on the edge and the things that were
before can be flipped and can be turned
to serve you know the new the new
principle the new logos and so for
example the story of Merlin usually goes
that he was the son of a devil or the
son of a dragon like you said but then
when he was born they baptized him and
then that flipped him and so he became a
servant of God though still having you
could say elements of where he came from
and so you know how a lot of modern
let's say a lot of modern experts on
Arthur will say things like Merlin is a
residue from Celtic mythology
Merlin is a remainder of drit ik
knowledge or druidic ideas that have
that have somehow found themselves in
the arthur and legend and and they kind
of say it almost like it's this
subversive thing but the the actual
reality is that yes you're right that's
exactly what merlin is it's only that
he's he it's taking the taking this
pagan thing and then flipping it so that
it can now participate in the story and
that's what christianity does all the
time
i always joke with with a lot of the new
pagans that you know it was christians
who wrote down the Eddas folks
christianity does all the time i always
joke with with a lot of the new pagans
that you know it was christians who
wrote down the Eddas folks is in the
middle ages had a copy some of you are
gonna find this horrible but on the
altar would have a copy of the bible and
would have a copy of the Iliad on the on
the altar because they saw the Iliad and
they saw the the Roman Sybil's and they
saw you know all these early all these
early things or even even Ovid's
metamorphoses they saw it as ultimately
pointing to Christ and all being like
shadows of Christ and so all these
stories were brought back into
Christianity and then kept in the manner
that they still have an edginess to them
but they ultimately serve a higher
purpose and so I think that that's what
that's what Merlin is I think that
understanding that aspect and
understanding Merlin is is what we all
need to understand now because we got to
do a lot of flipping got to start
flipping some things over right now
also Adam now says disregard enter slide
says disregard the first question so
Adam because I like you I let you have a
second I'll second a second question so
he said can you explain the top left of
this prodigal son icon with the Angels
and Seraphim and as circles and wings so
I can't I don't know if I don't think I
can show you guys but when you see an
angel that has it's like a circle and it
has eyes on it and wings if you look at
my recent my recent drawing of an angel
for this teacher that I designed you'll
see that it's a it's called a throne
it's a it's just a a kind of angel it
says stylization of a throne and it's
and it's meant to represent also in part
the idea of the wheels that um that
Ezekiel sees in his vision he sees the
the cherubs he sees that these four
cherubs that are kind of like these
these pillars and under the cherubs are
these wheels within wheels within wheels
and I and that is what they're supposed
to represent is it's a kind of angel but
it's also a this idea of the wheels so
Alex reader says hi Jonathan what is the
symbolism of private prisons or more
generally of the commodification of
justice hmm if that's still a bit narrow
could you talk more generally about what
it means to about there was something to
be a commodity and how that might relate
to the role of government of the state
thank you very much
after admit that I don't totally
understand the like they'd say the
purpose of your question um the idea
that there would be private prisons in a
in a Latina in a traditional world I
don't think would necessarily be a
problem in the sense that if the state
decides what's happening and you know
the private that prison is just owned by
a person you know I mean I don't think
that would be such a big deal
so I'm not sure what that means you know
it's like the the state
function is to set up is to set the
rules but then there are always
organizations that kind of live those
out you know you can imagine it somehow
like you know you see that in the Bible
the idea of the Pharisees for not
Pharisees the the publicans where the
Romans decided the Romans were the ones
getting the taxes but then they would
hire out you know people to get the
taxes for them and they weren't
necessarily the state they were they
were kind of like you know they would
just be given a contract to do that and
so I don't necessarily see a problem
with with that with prisons um if the
state if the let's say that the
authorities are involved in making sure
that the laws are followed and that
things are done properly
all right so Laura says you're talking
Boston was awesome with so many
evangelicals in the audience I assume
that they have a particular hunger for
the Christians of all across you how
many do you think eventually need a
church that has a rich history of
including the symbolic aspect of a
biblical faith I mean how many do I
think I think all of them you know I I
you know ultimately I hope that I hope
that the symbolic thinking can reach as
many people as possible in order to help
them see the Bible differently and think
differently and I think that that will
that will open up discussions that
couldn't be open before you know it's
very difficult for example for the
Orthodox to discuss with certain types
of kind of evangelical products it's
very different difficult it's like two
world that just aren't in the same place
and they're just missing each other you
know and you know if evangelical will
say something like you think you need to
you need to you know you need to
participates in the sacrament to be
saved so it's a kind of being saved by
doing this and this by following the law
and the Orthodox just doesn't know what
you're talking about like it's just
that's just not what it's about
and so just these two things they just
don't connect so hopefully hopefully we
can reach as many people
as possible
so white year 2 says I've been thinking
about the atonement and can't help but
read Colossians 2:13 14 through the lens
of a Protestant penal substitution Airy
model where God cancels our record of
debt and nailing it to the cross how
does the Orthodox tradition that view
that language thanks so much
here are the verses for reference and
you who were dead in your trespasses and
the uncircumcision of your flesh God
made alive together with him having
forgiven us all our trespasses like
canceling the record of debt that stood
against us with its legal demands this
he set aside nailing it to the cross
um I mean I think this is it's a great
verse it's an it's an amazing verse
because there's this beauty's beautiful
things brought together you know when
when when I talk about the patterns and
said Gregor Aneesa he doesn't make them
up you know he he really takes him from
Scripture but he he he wheezed them
beautifully so it talks about trespasses
death uncircumcision right of the flesh
and so it's tracing this idea of
something which is in the margin right
so you you trespass you you've stepped
aside you're not on the path you're not
aiming properly you've you've gone off
to the side then you're also dead
because of that you're outside of the
garden you're dead and you're
uncircumcised in the flesh you've
accumulated all this flesh on you and so
all of this this is powerful this
powerful thing until you you let's say
you accumulate think of think of it that
way think of it something like that this
this taking on of death is
is is in a way a an accumulation of debt
think of it that way it's maybe it's a
way to help people understand this stuff
so you know you God said you are
supposed to die he'll eat the fruit of
the knowledge whenever you're supposed
to die and then what happens is Adam and
Eve and the descendants they they start
to borrow from the outside they start to
take things from the outside add it to
themselves in order to preserve
themselves and kind of expand themselves
so that they don't die
and so they owe all this stuff that
they're that they're taking from the
outside they just oh it and and so and
that's a problem it's a problem because
it just ends up weighing you down and it
ends up keeping you in the world of
death and so Christ by taking all that
on himself by by dying he tramples down
death by death he he he and he by
accepting all of this willingly he's
he's able to pin that down to the cross
so that you can now enter into the
garden it's like I don't know to me
that's fine I don't think I the the idea
of the Penal substitutionary model is
it's or the idea of a substitutionary
model in the sense that Christ took our
place all of the stuff is not totally
absent in orthodoxy it's just not
central it's not the central tenant and
it's kind of like you can see it more
instead of seeing it as like the central
doctrine it's more of an image to try to
help you understand something which is
more mysterious or more fuller if you
take all the images in the Incarnation
together and put them put them together
that's my take on it anyways
so Jacob Jacob so are Jacob Jacob
Brussels asked me how do you handle
critique of these hard to grasp ideas
from fellow Orthodox Christians that's a
great question I mean I'll take critique
I always it's so funny because I I tell
you guys I'm not a theologian I tried to
I'm really a symbolist and an artist and
I and I see patterns in Scripture and I
see patterns in the Church Fathers and I
and I see the relationship between the
different ontological levels of reality
but I you know and I've said it several
times that I always feel very uneasy
talking about things like the Trinity or
the divine energies and all this stuff
and so to be honest like if someone
criticizes me and said that I've
misspoken or said something which is not
exactly right in terms of those things
that's totally fine with me I take it
back because that's not my purpose isn't
to teach people about that
I just tried to I'm mostly trying to
help people see a a symbolic structure
in order to help them view reality
differently but so don't take what I say
about the Trinity as being you know the
holy doctrine anyways you know to be
honest you should never and the thing
about that that's hilarious though the
thing about that it's hilarious is that
you shouldn't take the opinion of
someone like me who is not recognized by
the church as speaking with authority I
don't you know I have the blessing of my
priest and my bishop to make my carvings
to do these YouTube videos but I it's
not like they see me as this
authoritative father in the church that
has some kind of authority and so you
don't have to take people who don't have
that who are not you know in some regard
officially recognized by the church in
its hierarchy you don't have to take
those people's word for anything you
don't have to take their teaching as
being the thing that they teach
and that's also true for those that
question you everybody online thinks
that they have the authority to go after
everybody and to attack them you why do
you think we live in this weird
democracy where we think that that we
have the authority to go around and
criticize everybody else is everybody
else's orthodoxy you can do it and I do
it you see me do it but it doesn't mean
that it's an authoritative thing and you
and if someone comes at you some Rando
comes at you and starts to criticize you
you don't have to accept it I usually
you know it's happened to me a few times
where people are just really gone at me
and like writing mediums and saying that
I said this wrong that I need to take it
back publicly and I need to apologize
and at some point I just tell them you
know what dude go to my bishop you have
a problem with what I'm saying go to my
bishop tell my bishop convince my bishop
that I'm a heretic and and then we'll
speak because you I don't know you are
some Rando on on Facebook or something
so yeah sorry alright so here we go I'm
going to continue on here I'm going to
subscribe star so Nicola asks what is
the symbolic significance of pilgrimage
what is its purpose and how to do it
right have you personally been on any
pilgrimage that you would like to share
with us um I would say that I that I
haven't been on what I would consider to
be officially a pilgrimage I've been on
kind of semi pilgrimages but not nothing
that I would really not nothing that
would look like what I wish it was like
you know I've never been to a thoughts
I've never been to Jerusalem I would
really love to to go to those places I
feel like the times where I've been you
know to Greece or visited places like
that I felt like I was more of a tourist
than a pilgrim but if you understand
with the symbolic significance of a
pilgrimages you have to see it as
amazing mini version of a return to
paradise it's a
it's a microcosm of what it means to go
back into paradise go back up the
mountain and so you can imagine that the
mountain of paradise is the ultimate
center of the world the ultimate summit
of reality and then below that you know
if you look at medieval maps they would
have in the east at the summit of the
world kind of the way it was drawn it
was quite specific to in the east and
the summit you would have the Garden of
Eden that's kind of the summit of the
world and then down in the middle of the
map you would have Jerusalem so you can
understand this Jerusalem as acting as a
a lower version on the site imagine that
this ontological hierarchy a lower
version of what the garden is and so
going to Jerusalem visiting the holy
sepulchre or visiting you know the the
Church of the Nativity is this this mini
return to paradise and so if you if you
do go on a pilgrimage you should try to
see it as a as a spiritual journey as
well where you you know you should tried
to fast go to confession more try to do
to examine yourself try to pray in order
to prepare yourself so that the effect
of the pilgrimage on you will be more
transformative so that's so you can see
it but some people have smaller versions
of pilgrimages like for example you can
imagine someone who has some issue you
know some disease or some personal issue
and they it's a very specific thing but
now they want to find a solution to that
they're looking to to encounter to be
healed or they're looking to encounter
some some spiritual father and so it's
all the same which is at lower levels so
you can imagine you have this one
question you have a problem until you
take you take this problem to a Center
where meaning comes from and then that
place and you know the authority that is
there is going to answer your question
it's gonna heal your disease it's gonna
answer your spiritual question is going
to give you advice in order for you to
organize your chaotic life or chaotic
question okay so it's allways the same
tards the same pattern hopefully that
makes sense all right so now I jump into
patreon this is the the most questions
are here
all right so Dru McMahon asks is
Christian nationalism a viable term what
are your thoughts on this ideology
something to embrace or steer clear of I
think that I think that there is a
balance and what's going to happen is
that in the church in the different
churches not just in orthodoxy but in
Catholicism even in Protestantism you
will find groups that overemphasize one
side or the other and but I think there
is a balance I think that the unity of
reality does not deny multiplicity and
there's also this idea you see and say
Maximus we talks about unity without
confusion that is the purpose of our
unity is not to have this huge massive
mush of mixture but there is room for
particular identities to have their own
space to have their own their own
coherence you know as long as people
don't take so much pride in that
coherence that it that it actually
becomes pride itself where it actually
disconnects you from your communion with
others disconnect you from your
communion with God where you only see
your identity as completely opposed to
other identities where you all you want
to do is fight them off there has to be
a so there has to be this this balance
between unity multiplicity and so you'll
find people that hate any form of
nationalism they call it pilot ISM and
fanaticism is
officially a considered a heresy and the
Orthodox Church but when it usually
means is to view your ethnic group or
your your identity or lower identity as
the most important thing that's that's
definitely a heresy because any identity
is has its reality only to the extent
that it's connected to that which is
above it you can't you can't say I'm
just a Greek or I'm just a Russian you
always have to see it as a Greek in
communion with Russians in communion
with others around you all right it's
all but what we'll see and and we're
seeing it everybody is aware but we'll
see as Christianity erodes we're going
to see the two extremes appear we're
going to see a push for a mixture as if
mixture itself had some kind of value in
itself you know the idea that you know
that that this kind of weird joining of
all the different cultures of all the
different stuff you know like like a big
Bria bass that that somehow has value in
itself then you're going to see the
other side as well you're going to see
people who are going to put their foot
down we're gonna we're gonna really dig
their heels in and are going to want to
fight off anybody that is different and
was gonna want to protect their borders
at all cost
um and so yeah it's hard to find a
balance I agree D and all that stuff
because you always feel like you need to
choose a side
so a gars mamas half Jonathan I'm so
sorry then you have to enter too many
questions don't worry don't worry guys
so Rod Dreher says Rudra recently
published an article regarding the
corona virus calling the situation the
China apocalypse you still have the
energy we would love to hear your
thoughts and the symbolism of the corona
virus situation in China
um I haven't read rods article but it's
a serious what's happening now is going
to exacerbate a lot of the the problems
that we have because viruses
are all about they're all about identity
and infection they're all about borders
they're all about letting something in
from the outside which can kill you and
so what you're going to see and you can
see it look you saw it right away when
to the coronavirus exploded in in in
china what was the first thing I got
like in Canada the first thing the first
thing our our government said was don't
be racist against Chinese and I was like
I mean I wasn't surprised because
there's an analogy between the virus and
the foreigner you know it's just weird
that they right away jumped on that and
they were like the thing you need to
learn about the coronaviruses you
shouldn't be rat races against Chinese
and I thought it's it's a dangerous game
to play to push that because that once
the virus you've identified you trained
the question yourself you know by saying
don't don't be racist against Chinese
because of the coronavirus you've you've
created a frame but there are two there
are two sides to that frame and when the
coronavirus if it does become a multi it
does become a pandemic then the same
things going to flip and now it's going
to become the other side so it's some
scary stuff but for sure what we're
going to see is we're going to see break
down we're going to see how how
infection breaks down social structure
right so how chaos from below these
little bugs how they can come up and
they can start to eat at the world and
the world starts to fall apart
it starts to break the bonds between in
your body it's killing your body but
it's also destroying the social fabric
as it breakdown breaks and breaking down
the bonds and and it does so by now you
see this pendulum swing where it's like
here's the virus here's the virus eating
at the bonds of reality and in order to
respond to that we we create we isolate
things and so we we shut doors we put
people in quarantine and that but that
also in terms of the analogy between the
social level
and the personal level then that will
exacerbate the problem because as you
isolate people which you have to do your
your continuing but your continuing this
breakdown of the social fabric by
creating these these closed boxes in in
society um and as it if it gets worse
then we're going to see a lot more of
that and it does in fact seem that it
does in fact seem like if the moment
will the moment we see a totalitarian
regime arrived it could be it could be
something after a could be after a
pandemic because enough chaos is going
to call people are gonna are gonna beg
the government to come in and you know
bring the bring the sword down mmm so we
might see that in China we might see the
Chinese really cramped down on on their
people might not just in China we might
see it happen in Europe we might see it
happen wherever it is that that this
outbreak spreads yeah okay so so kay
asks it's gonna be a tough one so Kay
asked I'm having trouble understanding
this solution you gave to the cuckolding
problem
can you please briefly go over the
solutions to the inevitability of paying
tribute this is a really long to my
understanding it seems there must be a
part of an entity that is solely
dedicated to atoning for or on behalf of
the whole I believe the priesthood as a
scapegoat is a good example the
priesthood takes the pattern upon
themselves and allows the people to move
upward up the proverbial mountain that
as you speak up
as you righteously ascend more ground
land possibilities present themselves
and we get closer to the truest ideal or
principle in other words instead of
women and children being given to one or
a few men it is a few men or one man
giving themselves to the Lord you
continue with this ritual of atoning for
the pattern there is a gradual ship the
responsibility from the many that cannot
bear it to the few or the one that can
the chances of the women and children
atoning for this reoccurring pattern
becomes less and less yeah I'm totally
not sure I understand what you're I that
I don't think that's what another way of
solving the problem with the outsider
foreigner is acknowledging and
venerating it to the highest status as
possible am i misunderstanding the
solutions you gave I think you're
misunderstanding some of the solutions
you gave I mean I can answer just the
second part because I know that that
created quite a bit of stir when I
talked about this this foreign thing in
terms of Christianity and the conversion
of Rome how making it the highest thing
what I meant is also is making it a
crown making it above the world and so
by putting it above yourself you there's
a relationship between what is below you
and when it's above you you know there's
a relationship between the first and the
last all these things are related so by
changing the last into the first by
taking what is below and putting it
above and you can see it like you see it
in all kinds of stories you know where
the lowest thing becomes the king the
lowest peasant becomes the priest or the
the King marries the slave or or you
know or a serving girl
all this ideal taking the lowest thing
and bringing it up what it does is it
creates it then makes it possible for
the world inside to exist and the way
that it exists is that like I said in
terms of Christianity what happened is
that all of a sudden Rome could remain
roman and roman didn't become Jewish
people who think that Rome became Jewish
they're really
I mean it's very silly to think that
obviously not just look at how how
Constantinople got set up look at how
everything happened they didn't become
Jewish they took they took this Semitic
religion put it up and then participated
in it in a manner which made it possible
for them to remain who there were so
yeah that's and you know it's funny
because it's already like that you know
kings and kings in all cultures are
already like that it's hard for people
to understand that the so think about it
think of the story think of the fairy
tale story the princess has to marry
what she has to marry a prince and then
she and or the prince has to marry a
princess where does he find his princess
does he find the princess in the people
no he marries a foreign princess he
marries a foreigner and that happens
over and over and at some point the the
aristocracy is not the same people as
the the people below they're just not
there like a different breed of people
they're just not the same people you
know and you see that you see that
happen all the time look there's so many
examples of it another example in in the
Slavic people the Slavic people were
fighting for then we're fighting amongst
themselves you know the Scandinavians
came and at first they like kind of
chased them away and then they realize
wait a minute if we make the
Scandinavians our prince then we'll stop
fighting amongst ourselves because we
can't decide between ourselves who's
going to be the chief of the other one
so take someone from the outside put
them on top and then you stop
the infighting you see it happening
companies they take CEOs they rarely
take CEOs from the company usually they
use they tend to take a CEO from another
company because by taking something from
the outside putting in a top then
there's no you the the question of who
but among the people in the company is
going to be is going to be
chief is resolved because he'd take it
from the outside and you put it at the
top there's a million examples of that
hopefully that makes sense so sorry guys
as for the other part I don't I didn't
understand your your understanding of it
so sorry I don't want to put too much
time into it all right so Simona beige
asks I was born in the 80s and a lot of
cartoons I watched as a child had an
orphan as the main character and hero
that trope seems to have disappeared in
the cartoons I watched now with my
nephew and uses what is the symbolism of
the orphan and stories what would the
presence or absence of that trope in
mainstream 2 are telling mean for our
culture well first off I don't think
it's disappeared I think it's it's
definitely there I mean even the movies
that I don't particularly like for them
like frozen the two girls are orphaned
um you know and a lot of Disney movies
like The Lion King also orphan I mean it
just is actually most movies all the
Disney movies are it's always an orphan
and so you can you there's a there's a
lot of ways you can understand it one of
the ways is to kind of understand it has
this hero's journey as the as the
u-shape story where when if you have an
orphan you already have the downturn you
already have the idea that the identity
between the father and the son or the
mother the daughter is broken and so the
child falls into a lack of identity or
or a question of identity and then the
story becomes of how that person is able
to re-establish an identity having lost
their connection to where they came from
and so that's usually what it means so
you you know you're an orphan you lose
your connection and then you have to got
to go down and you have to come back up
with a more complete more complete
identity or something like that oh that
makes sense
alright so Isaiah Hale says what does it
mean that the altar of the Holy of
Holies are now in the east and the
entrance or exit of the church is now in
the West obviously it is related to what
Christ is but I can't pinpoint exactly
what I have an insipid idea that the
Christian Church is something like the
reflected image of the Jewish Tabernacle
so Jesus brings the ark and the altar
together into the east this is still the
westward movement that is in the
tabernacle just so far that it is
flipped to the other side of the earth
and now it's the east and the sunset in
the West with the exit has to do with a
final moment outward toward Zion maybe I
don't understand the second part of what
you said but I think you have a you have
a basic the question is a great question
you have a basic intuition of what's
going on um so the flip the flip that
happens in the in the church in part has
to do with the flip the flip between you
know when I talk about the left in the
right hand and I talk about two people
standing in front of each other and how
my right hand is your left hand and my
left hand is your right hand and and how
there's a flip when you change
perspectives that's what's going on here
it's a it's a change of perspective the
change of perspective has many many
forms I think one of them is the change
the conversion of Rome the courage of
Rome is super important in understanding
the story of Christianity it's extremely
important because it has to do with this
this restoration of of Cain you would
say this trying to resolve in duality by
restoring the restoring esau restoring
cain restoring this brother the
firstborn you know
hmm but then that also means there's a
flip and the flip happens in so many
strange ways do you see it you know the
in in Jewish tradition it seems for
example that you know Saint Michael is
is is kind of seen as the this angel of
mercy and Gabriel is seen as an angel of
rigor whereas in Christianity we see
Michael read with a sword and Mike and
Gabriel blue with the lily whereas in
the Jewish tradition it seems to be the
other way around so there's a lot of
these terms um but in terms of
Christianity you understand how it
happened it's that in the scriptures it
talks about Ezekiel talks about the the
final temple and in the this notion of
the final temple there's a sealed gate
in the east of the of this of the third
temple and the the sealed gate is the
gate through which the Messiah will come
okay so the idea is that the messiah
comes from the east and so you can
imagine it that he's coming in from the
east and he's moving in towards the west
to sit on his throne you know to sit on
the the mercy seat you could see it like
that so god is coming in from the east
and so this door is sealed until until
God reveals himself until the Messiah
comes into the world so the early
Christians according to st. Augustine
now the early Christians during the
liturgy in Rome for example or in other
churches the first churches they the
churches were facing west that is the
altar the Holy of Holies was in the West
and the the people were facing West and
the priests were facing east now this is
the this is one of the problems that you
see now in in modern Catholicism is this
confusion because the priests always
faced East they always faced East it's
just that it's the people that were
facing West and the priests were behind
the altar and were facing east and then
at some moment during the liturgy
everybody would turn around and would
face East
and the facing of the east was to face
the coming Messiah and is to be the
bride that receives the bridegroom
there's a there's a sexual symbolism
there's this whole idea of being us
ourselves being the ark in a way and
being the throne let's say that that God
comes and and sits upon okay so that's
how that that was the way that was done
and then ultimately what the Christians
did is to flip the whole thing around or
we're always facing east and we're
always there to receive the the the the
glory coming towards us and so then now
the whole symbolism of the apse becomes
the Rising Sun and you see the mother of
God
you know what their arms out and the the
Christ child in her womb as the son that
is on the horizon that's coming up from
the east to the west like it says in
Scripture that that is how the Son of
man will reveal himself and so that is
how it happened this turning it was kind
of playing out the actual the actual
logic of Christianity itself and and the
understanding of Scripture and the
apocalyptic reading of Ezekiel it was
all kind of that coming together and
creating this thing now in terms of the
the Holy of Holies one of the things
that I contend is that the Holy of
Holies in Christianity is a joining in
of everything together inside and so it
is both the Ark of the Covenant and the
altar at the same time and so everything
comes in it's just like and it's also
the place of the Crucified it's the tomb
and and those two things like the Christ
was crucified outside the city but it's
also the inside of the cave or that you
know this this total inside and so it's
like joining the inside and the outside
completely together in this higher
inside you would say or like it
transcendent inside something like that
divine darkness something like that
alright
so hopefully that makes some sense I
feel like I was rambling a lot on that
one but hopefully I kind of answer your
question
so normal cone a says can you please
speak to the mystery of the kingdom of
God has been granted to you but to those
outside everything comes in parables so
that they may look and see but not
perceive and hear and listen but not
understand in order that they may not be
converted and be forgiven and he says
what does this mean you guys have to
watch my videos I talked about that in
my recent video on the parable of the
sower you have to see this saying by
Christ as in balance with the parable of
the light under the bushel which comes
usually I don't know if it comes after
in every version of the Synoptics but
usually it comes right after and so you
have this parable which says you have to
come inside those that are inside will
receive those that are outside will be
cut off those that are outside will only
hear things that don't make a lot of
sense or just forms those that are
inside will receive the divine patterns
will be able to see the pattern of the
story that I'm saying and not just see
this random story and I have tried to
connect it for you guys with this idea
with one of the connections of it is is
an experience that a lot of you probably
had which is starting to see the
symbolic patterns and then all of a
sudden realizing that you were blind
before that that you you were listening
to stories you were watching movies you
you enjoyed them but you you could
really pierce them and so now all of a
sudden you feel like you've been brought
inside and you can see the light which
is hiding and so that's the first part
but then the second part of the the same
in the same text its Christ saying that
you should not put light under a bushel
that you should be the light of the
world that you should you know that
should shine in the darkness and so you
have to see those two together so I mean
you come in you get the patterns you
receive you
you you have this aesthetic motion
towards the the top of the mountain but
then once you get it Moses comes back
down with the law and give the law to
the people so once you get the pattern
then you can illuminate things and you
can point and show people what what
things mean you know that's just that
one version of it um and so that's what
that means you have to see you have to
see the two stories together you can't
isolate one all right okay so Justin
Seligman asks have you read any of the
Catholic Nevada eulogy theologians like
I'll hear the Lubeck Eve kaga Daniel ooh
if so what is your opinion of them and
their influence on Catholicism it seems
to you that there were attempting to
revive a sacramental ontology not unlike
your own work and what you would find
and and and that you would find many
points of agreements with them yes I
agree I flew back and Daniel ooh I know
for sure Daniel ooh was part of my
journey I read some of his texts on
Genesis early on when I was kind of
asking these questions and I think
you're right and you know there are
people like Balthazar as well are people
that seem to want to to regain a cosmic
vision of Christ and how Christ you know
appears in the world
um and so but I don't know I don't know
what they're up with their influences on
modern Catholicism I'm not I'm not sure
what that is and and also sacramental
like what what is their relationship to
to Catholic sacramentality but yeah
Daniel ooh I I remember really enjoying
his words when I read them so Richard
Anderson says first of all thank you for
all your work I'd like to know your
thoughts on the fulfilling of hedonistic
desires and if it holds any place in a
sober Christian worldview and lifestyle
I know you've spoken know you spoke on
how there are exceptions within certain
religions and cultures which I found to
be informative but I would like to know
your thoughts on how this
Thapa can be understood specifically
through the lens of christianity hope
this makes sense haha
well for sure there in in traditional
Christianity there's no place for the
fulfilling of hedonistic desires in the
way that we understand that today for
sure and the kind of in the way we
understand is you know we have this
hedonistic culture now for sure that's
not at all the case
what I pointed to there are a few things
one is that the desires are not bad the
church fathers all the church fathers
agree that our desires are not bad um
they just have to be pointed in the
right direction and they have to have
the right place in our human structure
let's say and there is a need sometimes
to have a kind of asceticism to rein in
the desires to prevent them from
becoming wild and taking over but you
know there's there's nothing wrong with
the desires themselves and so you would
say that oh the the basic desires are
resolved in God they can be resolved at
lower levels but they are ultimately
resolved in God and so they let's say
the the the desire to eat which can
become excessive and become atomistic is
resolved in communion communion in the
sense of of smaller communion where we
all will we eat together where we share
our food where we show when we
participate in each other's lives as
we're eating but then ultimately the
sacramental communion which is to
actually participate in God through
eating and the same thing goes with with
with sexuality the desire for sex which
can become atomistic is resolved in
marriage at the lower level in a normal
marriage between a man and a woman where
that desire also is a produces community
and produces communion as well Chris's
family and but then ultimately as
brought into our acting as the Bride of
Christ they are
are acting as the ones who are joined
with God in something which is analogous
to sexual Union so so that's how you
kind of deal with hedonistic desires
what I talked about when I talk about
the carnival is I talked about the idea
that on the edge at the end of cycles
there's usually a little valve that gets
opened and then you see some excess
which which is permitted in which
participates in society it's important
to understand that those carnivals are
always seems as suspicious by the church
authority and and and with reason to a
certain extent because that's what they
are they're suspicious they're margin
they're they're exceptions they're
upside down they're all this stuff they
won't go away you can't make them go
away and you and I think that for all
the times that the that the Church
officially pronounces against these
these carnivals they never went away
until modern times
um and so it doesn't mean that if you
participate in those carnivals and you
let yourself go doesn't mean it won't be
detrimental to your soul like you have
to be careful in those moments where
there is a you know when you you
participate in some kind of feast you
have to be careful because yes you can
feasts but there's always I mean who
knows where the line is it's not it's
different for for different people but
you know you can you usually know when
you've lost control of yourself and and
you have to be careful that it doesn't
yeah that it doesn't infect you any
longer in a longer relationship of loss
of control you would say so Jews I am a
gardius is there a direct connection
between the loss of Christian art and
the loss of Christian culture ie
symbolic language worldview yeah for
sure I I agree I think that there
definitely is I think that I think that
as the modern thinking started to appear
and the led to the architecture of the
church or the earthy eye
or the sacred chants started to be seen
as arbitrary then you know at first
people kind of surfed on what
Christianity had brought in terms of a
synthesis of of different cultures and
of different ideas of everything to
Europe and and at first they kind of
surfed on it for a little while but you
can just kind of start to degrade and
you know in the end you have Frank Gehry
and you're like what's going on what
happened you wake up from your drunk
stupor and you're like okay this is what
we have to deal with all right
so JD asked what is the symbolism in the
story of the Tower of Babel dude
I am NOT gonna answer JD that is an
amazing question but I should probably
make a video on that if you want me to
kind of go into it I mean I'll give a
brief idea of what it would what it is
and so but it could go into it a lot
more you know it's it's about the
problem of trying to unite everything
it's the problem of pride it's the
problem of believing that you can
contain everything then you can have one
language that you can have and you can
build something which will touch the sky
right that you can make something which
will be perfect and will not you know
will not need anything from the outside
and then it's like you're pulling the
pendulum on this side and you're like
you know we're gonna all contain
everything and then what happens pop it
breaks and then it scatters and that's
the pattern of a lot of things a lot of
things you see that happening so
Benjamin would asks would you agree that
one of the themes of the Old Testament
is the independent nation of Israel
being terrorized by empires with univer
left universalizing ambitions like Egypt
Babylon etc does this tell us something
about God's vision for the scale of a
polity how does this jibe with the
Christian Eastern Roman Empire and its
scale and still reading about Byzantine
tamata and their administration I don't
know much
um you know I would say I would say yes
I would say for sure not Egypt and
Babylon are definitely not the same
thing in the in the Bible but for sure
Babylon is this is Babel all right you
can just see it in the word it's the
same word babble babble on you know it's
the idea in Babylon you see it in the
story of Daniel and you see it in how
Nebuchadnezzar and the babylonian kings
how they did it was they tried to get
people from all these different cultures
and they they brought them to Babylon so
Babylon you know when it's in
Revelations it talks about the [ __ ] of
Babylon that Babylon is this [ __ ]
because it he maybe Knesset tried to
gather all the nations into one place
and to have this cohere thing which was
just all the nations at the same time
you know um and so that breaks down
right that's the also the Tower of Babel
you try to do that try to bring
everybody into one language one world
one government whatever and then what's
gonna happen it's going to shatter and
it's gonna break down and so I think
that for sure
Israel is is seen as a resistance to
that um Egypt is more complicated Egypt
Egypt is more complicated
maybe I should one day do a video on
Egypt you know what would be great as if
my brother Mitch here would agree to
talk about Egypt on my channel
hahahaha that's not happening you great
agree with them all right okay so so
does it tell us about God's vision for
the scale of a polity I would say I
don't know it's it's hard to say because
you need to find that balance but like
I've said a million times guys you know
the story ends with them with with a
city that is the size of everything the
New Jerusalem is the size of everything
you know that the outside of the city of
the New Jerusalem is absolute so there's
no narthex in the New Jerusalem
all right so Taylor Wilson asked what do
you think of dream analysis Thanks
we totally honest I think that I think
this is also something I think that is
backed up by the church fathers I think
that most of the time dreams are just
chaos and you have to be careful because
that's what it is most of the time you
know and and because it that's what
happens when you dream you dive you go
down into the water as you go down into
the chaos you go down into these
narratives that don't connect into these
things that aren't logical into this
world that is that it's kind of like
this this this this this world without
coherence but because of that once in a
while it can become like a mirror it can
act like a mirror so imagine the waters
below you know they're messy they're
there they're kind of these crazy waves
and they're there they're banging
against each other and that's usually
what dreams are then once in a while if
the water is very still then the Sun can
reflect perfectly in that water and so I
think that that's also why let's say
aesthetics and prophets and mystics will
have will have dreams that are more than
just than just chaos they'll have dreams
that are actually clear or like there's
crystal-clear reflection of of the
higher principles because the earth
doesn't reflect the higher principle the
earth absorbs them and so it's like you
get particulars but whereas the water
can act as a that's like a perfect
mirror once in a while and so it can
reflect the principle the really really
high principles that's why that's why I
think you see that happen all right
so James Cortinas I hope I pronounced
that right James your idea of a
resurrected Christianity as an answer to
the meaning crisis resonates greatly
with me what are your thoughts on Jordan
Hall and John travail Keys concept of
the religion that's not a religion are
these two frameworks compatible
I haven't listened I listen to their
first talk I haven't listened to their
there are subsequent talks I don't I
don't agree with John the - John John
and Jordan I think that that's probably
the place where we break that's probably
the place where I really don't agree
with them I I don't think that I don't
think that you can build religion and I
also don't think that saying that it's a
religion that's not a religion is going
to solve that problem I think that I
understand I have sympathy for people
that guys sympathy for people who've had
bad experiences with Christianity it's
like I understand but in the end I think
a lot of this is a is a KZ kind of
frustration with Authority and a refusal
to insert yourself in a in a hierarchy
it's kind of a desire there's something
there's something that is suspicious of
hierarchy in both of their approaches
and I understand you need to be
suspicious of hierarchy but I find I
find their suspicion of hierarchy to be
only one-sided you need to find a
balance between the kind of eminent say
the the emergent principle but in the
hierarchical principle and I and I and I
feel like that's what their that's what
they're missing and they would need to
connect to something which is above them
but hopefully I'll have a chance to talk
about that with Jon at some point you
know we're going to do an event in
Ontario this September with Paul Van der
clay as well so we myself genre Vicki
Paul van der clay and hopefully we could
talk about this stuff then because I do
appreciate John I think he's a like he's
he's very kind and he's very
understanding so so hopefully we can
talk about talking out but say so Maya
Oh JA la sorry I hope I pronounced
I have noticed with some concern that
determinism currently dominates online
discussion of free will can you explain
your basic position on the subject of
humanity's free will or lack thereof or
the positions of the church fathers it
would be most helpful if you could
explain how this will transcend the
material world do you believe it does
thank you so st. Maximus especially in
the church fathers in general I would
say they don't have the same vision a
free will that that uh that most people
have today which would the idea that
free will is somehow the capacity to
choose between things like that that is
in the free will for example like the
idea that that in the garden that the
the Adam and Eve could exercise their
free will by eating the fruit of the
knowledge of good and evil that is just
not the way that the church fathers
understand freedom to be free is to
choose God that's freedom that's free
will to not choose God is to be a slave
of something outside of you is to become
dependent on your passions on the
externals on the outside world it's on
the only freedom we have is to is when
we align ourselves with the will of God
and it that's so I know that that's so
counterintuitive with me for people um
and that's why if you read in st. Paul
you can understand st. Paul a little
more because the idea that you know you
you're free to sin and you're a slave to
God in and that is to be a slave to God
is to be free because you get your
you're attached to the do the thing that
causes you you're attached to the thing
that causes you and by being attached to
the thing that causes you you are free
from the things that are
that are you know around you the thing
that aren't you let's say or that that
are that are pulling on your attention
that are that are pulling you in all you
know all the idiosyncrasies you're free
from slavery to idiosyncrasies and so
you rise up via beyond you do sink
recedes and then you master them so you
you're you you then can engage with the
world there's nothing wrong with
engaging with the world you can engage
with the world in freedom as being kind
of above things and engaging with them
rather than being under them and being a
slave of your desires and your passions
and and all these all this other stuff
um hoping that answers that question in
terms of freedom um
so freedom just doesn't look so a lot of
the questions about free will can you
read them do just ring completely empty
for me and just read completely empty
because freedom actually looks like
submitting yourself to something higher
and that's what freedom ends up looking
like and so so it doesn't look like what
you think this idea of this absolute
freedom where you can you can choose God
or not choose God or you can choose
between two kinds of toothpaste all that
stuff is arbitrary it's arbitrary and
it's not it's not important and it's not
interesting all right Frank Raleigh asks
is there a difference between the
garments of skin provided by God and the
teaching of the watchers in the book of
Enoch hahaha Frank man great question
tough question the obvious answer is yes
but how does one differentiate and that
is some that is a really tough question
that is a tough question all right
right answer it this way it has to do
with the flip right it has to do with
the flip it has to do with turning death
against itself and so the idea the idea
that you would understand it that the
idea that the way that you would
understand it would be that man my mind
is going blank as the stuff is hard to
talk about okay so you turn death
against itself so you imagine how the
watchers that come and teach human
beings these skills that bring about the
degeneracy of the world and bring about
the fall that accelerate the fall
well the idea would be that in each of
those moves and each of those moves
there should be a way once the fall has
happened to use that skill and flip it
towards glory to flip it back up and
there's an intimation in Scripture of
that which is that Noah is Tecton Noah
is a artisan no no way is a you know
it's like no way is build an ark and so
you have these idea that all these
skills to modify nature are bringing
about the breakdown but then Noah
somehow he turns it and changes it for
the salvation of his family and the
salvation of the world right that's this
that's the turn and so there's also a
hint in that which is the tradition that
you find in the book of Jubilees I think
and in is it in the book of Jubilees I'm
not sure one of the in one of the extra
biblical texts it says that Noah married
nama and nama was the sister of
tubal-cain so the reason why you would
have this idea that Noah married nama is
that Noah who's a descent
of Seth marries the descendants of Cain
he's actually reproducing the pattern
that you see when it says that the sons
of God went into the daughters of men
you know how Christians have those two
traditions one is that the angels that
went to the the daughters of man the
other it's that the sons of Seth went
into the daughters men and I'm always
telling guys doesn't matter which way
you take it the meaning is the same the
symbolism refers to the same thing so
Noah who's the son of Seth
Mary's daughter Cain he's also a Tecton
but he flips it and it becomes to the
salvation of the world and so that's the
difference now you know I don't know I
don't know what it is for each thing but
that would be the idea it would be that
that every technology has in it the
possibility of destruction and and
breaking down the world but it also
should have the possibility of positive
and being a flipping um but maybe it
needs a saint you need a saint to do
that I don't know hmm all right so all
of our Erickson tax do you think that
there is a materialistic explanation of
the miracles in the Bible or do you
think like John Lennox that God feeds in
a new event I would say that there these
are irrelevant questions sorry Oliver
irrelevant I'm sorry man I just I feel
like I'm a jerk answering it that way is
that the purpose of telling the story of
a miracle in Scripture is not so that
you understand the mechanical
causalities which brought it about there
are obviously mechanical causalities
because it's an event in the world so
there are obviously secondary causes for
all the miracles described in Scripture
I don't know what they are I don't care
those do not oppose the intervention of
the divine logos appearing clearly in
the world that the will of God appears
in the world in a way that is more
meaningful that is fuller that it has
more impact
you know that's usually what a miracle
is a miracle like I've said many times
before mmm
if a rock falls off a cliff that's not a
miracle if if your if your enemy is
attacking you and you're praying God and
as you're praying God the rock falls off
the cliff and crushed your hand it
crushes your enemy that's a miracle
miracles are the place where meaning and
phenomena are so joined together that
they shine really really brightly you
know um and so I don't know like what
the material causes are of the miracles
and and I don't know like I don't I
don't know they're I don't I don't try
to find what's under the description in
the story i dint it I tend to see the
story as being sufficient in terms of
description of what the person
encountered like I said I don't I don't
think that people that the stories in
the Bible are made up like I don't think
that it people's were just sitting there
making up stories I think that they are
description of events and those are the
description of the events we have
there's no use to try to go under them
and try to to figure out you know you
you get you get that news here these
people who you know you've heard this
you've heard all the explanations of you
know like the crossing of the Red Sea
that that maybe there was this wind and
this there's this special wind that
comes once every whatever and you could
have blown the water so that it would
spread the water and you're like you
know what dude this is useless
you're not you're not helping your soul
by by thinking about this stuff alright
sorry I'm sorry guys if I'm if I'm like
this I don't know why it gets me this
coughing it's got driving nuts
alright so Kevin Patterson asked what is
the relationship between symbolic
liturgy esotericism and the modern
notion of cult what is the relation
[ __ ] between modern liturgy esotericism
and the modern notion of cult i mean
those words are so full like the word
esoteric now is just so ruined it's just
completely it's been been ruined
you know when someone thinks that
esoteric has something to do with
crystals or something it's like it's so
ruined let's say this way it's like if
you read when you you meet some worth
about Reese who refuse to use the word
sacrament for example they only use the
word mystery and they talk about the
mysteries of the church and you have to
be initiated into the mysteries of the
church they're not afraid to use that
language which was used by the Church
Fathers which is a language that kind of
pseudo religious cults and the modern
cults will use that language right and
so on the other hand you have other
people who freak out when they hear
Christians talk about initiation and
talk about the mysteries and you know
how this idea that people were prepared
and that baptism is a form of initiation
it's like people freaked out because
they have these modern occult kind of
weird occult stuff to refer to and so we
just have to be able to separate the
wheat from the chaff you know I think
you know I've said it before like III
have some sympathy for modern let's say
kind of 19th century style cultists like
I have some sympathy for them in the
sense that I think that one of the
things they wanted was they saw how
Christianity around them was so stale
was so devoid of mystical reality was so
devoid of cosmic significance that they
that they that they kind of created
these weird alternatives that were that
had these kind of initiative the
initiation structures and all this stuff
but I think that the best of that is in
the church already it's in you know it's
in the Christian the Christian liturgy
I think that's the best I can do with
that all right guys it's almost 10:30
I'm gonna I'm gonna now go into the
super chats and see what we got and
sorry I don't feel like I'm being a jerk
a lot of these questions I don't know
what's going on with me I think it's a
suspicion that I have the corona virus
which is really dragging alright okay so
let's see this okay all right so I might
not be able to get through all these but
I will try
okay so Andre Johnson asks the question
what makes the Christian story the most
important why can't it sit on the next
shelf to the Greek and North Smith on
the shelf next to the Greek in Norse
myths well I'm gonna give you you know
what I'm gonna give you a very practical
answer to that I'm not gonna give you a
metaphysical and I could give you a
symbolic yeah give you the symbolic
reasons why I think that the story of
Christ resolves all the story it's
talked about a quite a few in a lot of
my videos but I could I could tell you
the basic reason very practical reason
is that those stories are gone no one no
one lives in those stories anymore no
one really worship Zeus anymore people
who think they worship Zeus our zoos are
pretending they're they made it up it's
a it's a kind of weird syncretic you
know pseudo religion you know and it's
same with the north's no one really
worships Odin there it's all it's all
role play it's all they're all
pretending you know they're making stuff
up the link that the connection between
those realities have been cut
and if you don't if you don't it's I
understand that people wish that didn't
happen but it did happen and and you
know who did it
it's your ancestors that did that it's
not something from the outside not some
outer magical weird thing called the
church that dropped in and cut those
links it's us it's our ancestors that
did that and so the reason why the
Christian story is the most important is
because it's the one you can live in you
can you can actually be in that story it
can be your story that's it man I hope
that answers that
all right so Charles snippy says hello
do the Mormons share are many of the
securin scriptures where and why do they
go wrong it's finding having the key to
understanding the patterns um I mean I
think Jewish the Mormons are very
different you know they're very very
different yeah
Jews have the what we call the Old
Testament they have the the Tanakh and
so they end the Torah and they have
those old books and they have their own
traditions and from a Christian
perspective they did not recognize that
Christ was the Messiah they didn't
recognize that whereas Mormons Mormons
it's just it's weirder Mormons they they
they kind of build on this rediscovery
it seemed like they build on the
rediscovery of a lot of the apocryphal
texts in the nineteenth century and and
then they kind of mix all that together
and they created like another revelation
but I don't know enough about Mormonism
it just it just seems to me when I when
I see it to be a very modern
materialistic religion now this idea
that everything that gods are that gods
live on other planets and that kind of
stuff like III if there are Mormons out
there that that tell me that they don't
believe that or that it's some kind of
symbolic language to speak about
something else I'd love to talk to you
but uh but that seems to be my
understanding that it it's a very modern
religion in the sense that it's actually
very materialistic believes that that
everything is material and and I can't
just can't drive with that it seems like
no one today can believe that anymore
you can't believe that things are only
material because the material scatters
into into quantum flux or whatever it
just falls into potentiality all right
okay so Jonathan aught for twenty dogs
all right so Charleston gave five euros
Andrew Johnson 10 USD Charles oz for $20
says like Ethiopians and Armenians
certain ethnic groups to Christianity
into their identity what do you think a
Christian a Jewish Christianity look
like since there are some Dusit today
who believe in Christ today even in
Israel
hmm I think I think that Syrian
Christianity was probably like early
Syrian Christianity was probably if you
want to see what Jewish Christianity
would look like that's probably what it
looked like when you read you know even
the the Syrian saints like said Isaac
and Saint Ephrem you know they stayed
definitely you can see that they
definitely have some insight into Jewish
tradition that some of the Greek fathers
don't have and that's why one of the
reasons why saying after the Syrian I
think his his hymns are paradise and his
hands in general are so important
because they bring within the Christian
Church the imagistic thinking that that
the Jews had at the time some of it you
can still find in the father's but but a
lot of it seems to have kind of eroded
whereas Saint Ephrem just it just shines
all right so Brad's pit that's questions
before $5 it was deep how do you stop
watching porn Wow I don't that's a five
dollar question Brad all right so or how
do you gain control of the passions also
what's the symbolism of porn and why
is it bad um so I talked about you know
I talked about this before the symbolism
Christianity that symbolism itself is
the gathering in of the particulars of
something into its unity and that the
coexistence of the particulars with the
one right that is the symbolic process
and so the symbolism of sexuality has
several elements and there is a that's a
pleasurable there's pleasure
there's communion with your spouse
there's the creation of offspring and
the family and there's how all of this
is also becomes an image or a way to
manifest the union of the humanity with
God okay so that's what sexuality is now
every time that you start to split those
apart every time you take one element
you just pull it and you try to keep it
on its own that will lead you towards a
downfall it'll lead you towards an
addiction it'll lead you towards being
completely subjugated to your passion
and so yeah and it can do and if you do
it the other way around like if you pull
just the practical part of of sexuality
and trying to make it just about having
kids it's going to you know when I talk
about this the idea that st. Maximus on
the right hand right hand sins you start
with the right hand sinned or you tried
to control and to be self-sufficient and
then pride and then here comes the left
hand in the wake of that and so if you
do that then you see any comeback you
see that in the early 20th century for
example the priests here they had
something called the Revenge of the mmm
that vows death so the revenge of the
crib where they thought that if French
Canadians could have more children than
they would out breathe the English and
the couch it in also spiritual terms
the forced women to have kids every year
the priest would actually name the women
at the front of the church when they
weren't having children every year to
shame them into having children and if
you do that what happens you know you
get a flip you get a break and then it
flips to the other side and it becomes
you know sexual revolution or whatever
and so you need to keep those things
those things together
that's what sexuality is for so how do
you gain control of the passions how do
you start watching porn
you have to pray and you a good way to
do it would be to have someone I could
talked about can I talk to you guys
about confession like confession is
really great because one of the problems
with not with a bad habit is that it
becomes like this weird pattern that
just repeats itself and and if you
noticed in your own self when you have a
bad habit sometimes
if you have a massive change in your
life you know then it can be an
opportunity to get rid of a bad habit
because the massive change disrupts
these these kind of insipid patterns
enough to create what you could call
like a new beginning you know and so you
if you're Protestant you know for for
all the times that I've criticized the
altar call the altar call can do that
can help you going up for an altar call
can be a moment like a cathartic moment
where you you create a new beginning and
you know and then you can kind of ground
yourself on that to start again you know
in in the Orthodox Church I think that's
what confession is the best use of
confession is that every time you go to
confession try to see it as a clean
slate for to try to kind of do to to to
to start yourself again and the second
okay so here's a more practical thing
about that is that the prob
then you have when you fall into those
kinds of senses you forget yourself you
forget and there's a there's a moment
there's a moment where you switch
there's a there's a moment where you you
you could say you lose consciousness
actually you kind of lose consciousness
and then the the porn addicted version
of you
takes over right and it's so strong that
you know once you get once you're on the
other side of your sin you know once
you've eaten the cake once you've drank
you know once you've drank the six-pack
once you you know whatever it is that
your sin is then it's almost as if you
immediately look back at that person who
did that and you don't recognize them
because it's like a demon it's like you
have like a demon you have a there's
like an aspect of you which is
completely isolated and is taking over
and so the way one of the ways to to not
have to not fall is to remember yourself
is to be attentive and to not forget so
be attentive to the times if you're
watching for and be attended to the
times that you do that like when is it
that I watch porn what what are the what
are the things that lead up to that
you know usually there are a few things
that will lead up and you kind of always
end up in the same place so what are
those things identify those things so
that you recognize the first things
before you fully forget yourself you see
right away it's like oh I don't know
like I don't know what it is depends on
your story like it's like Oh am I going
to my computer at 11:00 at night like a
why am i doing that you know or am I
like whatever it is you're doing it's
like you you know what the steps are so
you have to stop yourself before you
have to remember yourself um one of the
ways that I've kind of gotten rid of bad
habits is for example I've given myself
something I need to do before I indulge
in the
have it so it's like okay I'm I before I
do this before I fall I have to do
something I don't know what it is like
it could be anything you could be you
have to you have to write down your name
and a book or you it could be anything
the idea is to create steps between the
moment you fall and the moment that
you're you know that the moments where
you still remember yourself to create
some intermediary step that where you
can break and you can stop the demon
from coming in and taking over you know
a good way is also to use the Jesus
Prayer that works for a lot of people
too is to repeat to repeat the Jesus
Prayer Lord Jesus Christ son of God have
mercy on me a sinner
and to repeat that in your mind in order
to not forget yourself and to not to not
lose your to not to lose consciousness
for that moment it takes for you to
become that other person so those are
some tricks you can have there's a lot
of so many things you can do you can
know if you know the places where you
are when you indulge in that kind of
stuff then you can create reminders of
yourself for yourself you know you can
have something up on the wall you could
have your background of your screen
being an image of Christ you could you
could have like there's all kinds of
things you could do in order to help you
remember and not forget all right
hopefully that is good all right so
Breck here Wow brick here on a roll
$1.99 giving me super stickers $50 well
Rick here and $1.99 USD as well thank
you bunch of people giving me stickers
wow you guys thanks a lot murky
forgotten brick here again again again
thank you so skylark $9.99 USD I'm
having trouble reconciling Satan as the
enemy versus merely an accuser is it
right to say evil Satan has no
subsistence beyond man's limit imitation
become
young man's invitation of man instead of
God in other words who is safe I don't
that I don't think I totally understand
you second part of your sense but so so
you can understand you can understand
the idea that Satan is so you use the
different image so we say Diablos right
the one who who splits apart we say the
accuser we say the enemy and all those
things are related to each other so you
can understand it as you can understand
it as something which is outside of you
looks at you and sees how your how your
failing how your not what your supposed
to be right so think of it of how you
judge your neighbor you know you look at
your your mother and you say you know
you're not the right you're not a good
mother right and so when you do that
you're being satanic you are you know
your you are something here here's a
good example right okay so Christ says
you know he has to die Peter says you
know it's like no no no right no you're
not gonna die
nope and so what does Christ say he says
get behind you saying cuz cuz because
Peter was saying that's not what the
massage should be this is what the
massage should be the Messiah should be
this and so when you when you judge when
you accuse that's that's what you're
doing
right and so Satan is the
Kosmic version of that and so he accuses
us of not being in the image of God but
at the same time he also it's the weird
thing but he's also the seducer he's
also the one who who kind of pulls us
away who kind of pulls us who separates
us and he pulls us away by on the one
hand telling us you know we should or
could be like God on the other hand
telling us that we're not like God that
we're not living up to what we should be
and so all of those things kind of are
related together so that's as close as
I'm gonna get in terms of explaining
saying you so I hope that that was I
hope that that was useful kind of
running out of voice here guys all right
so I've got a few more I don't know if
I'm gonna get through all these all
right we're almost it's 1044 men
so Andrew Nelson says $5 when you
reference 19th century occultism does
that make from Mormonism can you expand
on why you think those called still
exist today I don't know enough about
Mormonism be honest I don't really know
enough about it I'm not not honest I'm
not a big fan I think that my perception
of them is rather negative but I don't I
don't know enough to talk about it so
when I'm talking about 19th century
occultism I mean you guys know what I'm
talking about you know I kind of have
you know any fast levy and and a few and
a lot of the French occultist and then
some English occultist it's like i like
i said i i I don't agree with them um
and but I understand their frustration
let's say with Christianity but
Mormonism is really a weird materialism
I don't know know someone we need to
tell me more about Mormonism
all right so Alan
you might not know because Valtor
countries are very small the worship of
pagan gods is just as real as going to
the church but I don't know are you I'd
have to see proof of that that's a very
interesting idea what do you think of
Hinduism haha where do I think of India
yeah I like them I like the Vedas I like
yeah there are some like I think that
you read advised Vedanta you get some
really fascinating insights I don't
agree with everything I think that I
think that a lot of the questions that
they were asking were were very good
questions very interesting questions um
and I think that the word that notion
Hinduism is a very strange notion
because it's Hinduism is like so big
it's so huge um so I guess that's as
close as I'm gonna get to answering that
question alright guys I think I think
we're done I think we're done um so last
maybe this is gonna be the last one guys
okay shot in the dark 5 USD says are we
are are you familiar with kicker guards
thought and what is your opinion of it
all man you asked that question at 10:45
not good I can't answer that
hahaha yes I am familiar with kicker
guards thought and I think that um I
think that there are some interesting
things in there I think that there are
some things which are just really not
interesting um let me get back to that
some other time because this is it's
like my mind is just becoming mush now
hopefully maybe one day I'll make a
video on key guard or something I keep
saying maybe you want to tell make a
video on this or that so guys thank you
for your time everybody really
appreciate this and like I said YouTube
is is really playing a number on me and
so if you like what I'm doing please
share my videos and thank you to
everybody who has been supporting me you
know the the financial support is really
you know it's one of the reasons why I
feel like I
I've been able to now put together this
this new blog where everybody's good
where other people are gonna start to
get involved gonna be like a training
ground for symbolic thought you know um
it's giving me the possibility to to do
a lot of stuff so thanks again and I'll
see everybody next month and thanks to
our moderator as well I think I saw
Jacob and Kristian Chad and Lisa is
there as well all my main people and I
will see everybody next month alright so
bye bye